متابعه للوضع الميداني في الخرطوم معنا من
هناك مراسله الجزيره هيثم هيثم كيف يبدو
الوضع في في هذا الوقت
حسن الوضع حاله من الهدوء تسيطر على وسط
منطقه وسط الخرطوم بعد ان شهدت اشتباكات
عنيفه طيله ساعات اليوم ولكن رغم هذا
الهدوم ما تزال من الحين الى الاخر تسمع
اصوات لطلقات واصوات لاشتباكات
وكلما ابتاع ابتعدنا اكثر في الصوت الذي
ياتي من اماكن بعيده صوت ايضا ربما
اشتباكات في مسافات اصبحت ابعد من هذه
المنطقه التي تعد منطقه استراتيجيه هنا
منطقه وسط الخرطوم التي تحوي كافه المقر
الاستراتيجيه للدوله من القصر الرئاسي
الجمهوري وايضا القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه والكثير من المؤسسات
الحساسه في البلاد كانت هذه المنطقه شهيدا
يعني قتال عنيف طوال الساعات الماضيه ولكن
الان هدات الاوضاع بشكل كبير كما
نشاهده ونتابع يعني انخفاض اص الاسلحه
والاشتباكات ولكن في مناطق اخرى ربما ما
تزال هناك اصوات نسمعها تاتي من بعيد في
مناطق اخرى يعني
ايضا نسمع صوت لتحليق طائرات
الان وما تدل يعني من الصباح كان هناك
العديد من الطلعات الجويه لسلاح الجو
السوداني في سماء الخرطوم وربما قد استهدف
عدد من المواقع الان يعاود الطلعات بالليل
كما نسمع في هذه اللحظات هذه طلعت الجويه
لسلاح الجو السوداني ولكن عموما اليوم كان
يوم عصيب للشارع السوداني لسكان الخرطوم
بشكل خاص مع هناك كانت مناشدات من لجنه
اطباء السودان المركزيه
للمتحاربين من هناك مرضى في بعض
المستشفيات القريبه من مقر القياده العامه
خاصه المرضى غسيل الكلى هل حجزوا الجراء
هذه الاحداث ايضا هناك كانت طلاب في بعض
المدارس
كمدرسه كموني في وسط الخرطوم مناشرت كانت
المتحاربين بضروره افتح المجال لخروج حول
المحجزين
واضح انكم تتابعون الوضع الميداني عن عن
كثب الان هدوء حذر هناك تحرك لطائرات سلاح
الجو لكن هل
امكنكم معرفه ما الذي يدور حول المقرات
الرئيسيه في وسط الخرطوم المقرات السياديه
الاساسيه في وسط الخرطوم اكان القياده
العامه المسلحه او حتى القصر الجمهوري او
حتى الجسور الاساسيه التي تربط العاصمه او
نواحي العاصمه
حسن قبل اكثر من الساعه تحدث الينا مصدر
عسكري من القياده العامه في الجيش
السوداني وقال بان القوات الجيش بسطت
سيطرتها على معظم الاماكن الاستراتيجيه
خاصه القياده العامه والقصر الجمهوري وفي
تلك الاثناء التي كانت تدور فيها
الاشتباكات في وسط العاصمه قال بان ما
يجري الان هو التعامل مع من قال بانها
جيوب لقوات الدعم السريع التي تتم
مطاردتها خارج هذه
الاماكن هذا ما قاله المصدر العسكري لنا
في الساعات الماضيه ولكن كما تسمع لهذه
الطلقات من حين الى الاخر تنطلق في هذه
المناطق القريبه من وسط الخرطوم ولكن
ميدانيا على الارض بحسب المزرعه العسكري
الان السيطره للجيش ولكن الدعم السريع
ايضا يقول في بيانات مختلفه انهم يسيطرون
ايضا على مواقع ان ذات المواقع
الاستراتيجيه في في الخرطوم
بشكل واضح لا نستطيع ان نجلي او نجزم
بسيطره هذه الاماكن من يقف عليها بشكل
فعلي لانه حتى الان لم يعني تخرج او يخرج
اي مسؤول من هذه المواقع ويدلي بتصريحات
سواء كان من داخل قصر الجمهوري او من
القياده العامه للشعب ليبين طبيعه الموقف
وطبيعه الوضع الميداني هناك ولكن هذا
الهدوء الذي تعيشه
المنطقه الوسط الخرطوم ربما ينبغي على ان
بالفعل هناك
جهه تسيطر على الموقف وربما كما قال
المصدر العسكري الجيش انه ربما يفصل
سيطرته على هذه الاماكن